et pour en parler nous sommes avec
alexandre del valle géopolitologue
écrivain auteur de la mondialisation
dangereuse aux éditions de l'artilleur
bonsoir alexandre del valle merci d'être
avec nous le président donc qui sont les
prix aujourd'hui à son précis puissant
après décès seraient ils accusent
d'avoir favorisé l'émergence d'une caste
de riches est ce que c'est c'est une
accusation qui est fondée selon vous
je n'ai pas les détails mais il est vrai
que l'ancien président avait instauré un
pouvoir personnel est assez autoritaire
liés à ceux qui ne pouvoir oligarchique
et c'est une lapalissade que de dire
qu'il est qu'il existe une oligarchie
encore en partie liée à l'ancien
président qui a longtemps régné qui a
mis tous ces gens en place et il est
vrai aussi que les troubles imputés à
des à un terrorisme international par
les uns ou à l'occident par les autres
ce sont essentiellement des troubles
entre un ancien président et son
successeur ce dernier n'ayant pas réussi
à acquérir toute la légitimité la
popularité nécessaire et ayant un peu
échappé à non pas à l'ancien mais à la
clique et au pouvoir oligarchique qui
étaient autour de de l'ancien président
est forcément cette clique veut rester
en place c'est quelle configuration
assez classique dans une succession qui
se passe mal et un est indicible qui
échappe à son créateur ça veut dire en
gros affaire interne au pays fin de
l'histoire
en fait c'est comme en médecine selon
plusieurs paramètres qui se croisent il
y a cette dimension que je me décrire il
y à aussi effectivement ce qui n'est pas
tout à fait infondées même si c'est un
prétexte en partie invoqué par les
membres de l'ocf l'organisation à
conférence de shanghai qui a été créé
d'ailleurs en 2001 pour combattre
officiellement entre autres le
terrorisme islamiste et pour instaurer
un ordre multipolaire avec le kazakhstan
est un pays très stratégique dans
l'alliance de shanghai et il est vrai
aussi que le kazakhstan comme
l'ouzbékistan
comme tous ces pays
turcophones d'asie entre âge mais
l'azerbaïdjan un peu de côté sans
menacer on pourrait parler aussi d'un
pays dont turcophones le
tadjikistan mais ces pays d'asie
centrale ex soviétique sont très menacés
par des mouvements islamistes radicaux
liés au terrorisme international d'al
qaïda ou de dèche et un peu les deux
maintenant et c'est que c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement ont connu l'un des
membres fondateurs l'un des groupes
fondateurs d'al qaïda dans les années
80-90 était le mouvement islamique de
l'ouzbékistan qui est très présent dans
toute l'asie centrale et ces pays sont
marqués par la laïcité marxiste par une
anti religieuse ite et un traitement
impitoyable des islamistes qui ont été
réprimées dans tous ces pays et il est
vrai que quand il ya des troubles
internes et bien des mouvements
islamistes peuvent être tentés de se
greffer sur un trouble comme on l'a vu
dans un endroit très différents au mali
où des laïcs berbères ont été rejoints
par des djihadistes et donc c'est pas
entièrement faux de dire qu'il ya des
menaces terroristes islamistes qui n'a
jamais supporté c'est pouvoir laïque
liés à la russie est héritée de l'ex au
soviétisme marxiste alors on voit que
l'europe réagit un quart ap aujourd'hui
au respect du pays au respect des droits
de l'homme la diplomatie américaine
aussi qui a donné son opinion
est ce que l'europe l'occident d'une
manière générale à la bonne lecture de
ce qui s'est passé au kazakhstan selon
vous je ne suis pas sûr aujourd'hui il y
à un prisme tout ce qui est dans
l'alliance trop russe ou pro chinois zhu
wen au cs l'alliance de shanghai donc
tous ceux qui sont proches en gros de
l'ex monde soviétique et de la russie
mais aussi de la chine qui est également
très proche du kazakhstan on pourrait
dire un bloc soviétique ou ex
communistes ou communistes et bien tout
ce qui vient de ces pays est
systématiquement considérés comme
suspects comme faut tout ce que disent
ses dirigeants sont toujours tout est
toujours considéré comme fort il ya
quand même un prisme un peu guerre
froide ça n'empêche pas que dans ces
pays il a des dictateurs absolument pas
mon propos de le nier mais il y à une
suspicion de principe et quoique c'est
comme quand il ya un meurtre en russie
c'est forcément tout in quand même si en
fait parfois c'est peut être une mafia
il ya un a priori et ça ça ça peut
empêcher une lecture saine que de ne pas
voir la complexité il peut y avoir un
peu de ça mais il ya aussi d'autres
paramètres une instabilité une menace
islamiste terroriste est aussi un
problème d'inégalité de pauvreté le
kazakhstan est un des pays les plus
riches du monde avec des mines et des
réserves d'hydrocarbures mais aussi avec
aussi alors qu'à pas une énorme
population c'est une très faible densité
mais en même temps avec des gens très
pauvres et qui ont été appauvris encore
plus depuis la crise qu vidée depuis la
hausse des prix des hydrocarbures donc
ce que l'occident ne voit pas dans son
moralisme qui pointent toujours les
mêmes c'est qu' il peut y avoir cela
mais il ya aussi d'autres paramètres et
c'est dommage d'oublier d'autres
paramètres y compris des ddd rivalité a
entre ses ces méchants des spots que
l'occident conspué le ils sont pas
toujours d'accord entre eux et moi je
pense que la vraie grille de lecture
c'est c'est cette opposition entre
un président et son successeur cetc
greffer là-dessus le problème des
inégalités qui réel et qui depuis des
années a été étouffée par le régime
quand même assez autoritaire merci
beaucoup à des centaines wallemme nous
avoir apporté votre analyse